el aumento gradual del salario mínimo en
argentina será mayor de lo esperado el
anuncio lo hizo el gobierno después del
reclamo de miles de manifestantes que
salieron a las calles de buenos aires no
sólo a pedir un alza salarial sino a
pronunciarse en contra del pago de la
deuda con el fondo monetario
internacional
[Música]
en marzo se había concertado una alza
gradual del 35 por ciento hasta febrero
de 2022 pero ahora está 16 puntos por
encima en ese momento el ingreso mínimo
era equivalente a 230 dólares y hoy es
de 296 dólares mensuales el nuevo
incremento ocurrirá en tres etapas
progresivas según lo acordado por el
consejo nacional de empleo en septiembre
será de 316 dólares en octubre de 325
dólares y en febrero de 2022 llegaría a
33 mil pesos argentinos o 335 dólares es
decir un aumento final del 52% y no del
35% como se había acordado en marzo de
este año y dos puntos por encima de la
inflación estimada pero muy por debajo
de los 711 dólares que reclaman los
sindicatos
[Música]
sin embargo argentina de 45 mil millones
de dólares al fondo monetario
internacional del crédito stand by
firmado por el ex presidente de derecha
a mauricio macri en 2018 tan solo en
2022 el gobierno debe desembolsar 19 mil
millones de dólares que dice no tener
siendo más conocerla la cuenta con el
fondo monetario que como se hace para
salir de la situación en serie las
medidas para contrarrestar la pobreza e
impulsar el mercado interno se dan
después de la pérdida electoral del
oficialismo en vez de discutir cómo
solucionar los problemas estructurales
del país que fue el cachetazo que que
recibió el gobierno en las elecciones lo
que hacen en un gabinete a la derecha
completamente
argentina es el cuarto país en la región
con el salario mínimo más bajo después
de venezuela brasil y méjico